el concepto aprendizaje para el dominio
se usa mucho en estos días pero quise
hacer un vídeo sobre él porque puede
significar cosas distintas para
diferentes personas y quiero hablar de
lo que significa al menos en el contexto
de khan academy para brindar algo de
perspectiva comencemos con el
aprendizaje tradicional veremos en qué
funciona y en qué no funciona y a partir
de ahí nos daremos cuenta de por qué el
aprendizaje para el dominio puede
abordar algunos de estos problemas
digamos que estamos en una clase de
matemáticas de secundaria y en este
momento el grupo está enfocado en
números negativos trabajamos en esto un
par de semanas y después de dos semanas
de elecciones y tareas hacemos un examen
luego observamos a cierto estudiante que
obtiene 80% de aciertos en ese examen
sabe bastante del tema pero hay algo
aquí que no sabe aquí hay algo más que
no sabe ya que hay algo que tampoco sabe
estas son lagunas en su comprensión
voy a etiquetar las correctamente son
lagunas y aunque nos tomemos el tiempo
para hacer una
evaluación un examen breve e
identifiquemos esas lagunas todo el
grupo incluido este estudiante avanzará
al siguiente concepto digamos que el
siguiente concepto en el que vamos a
trabajar quizá otro par de semanas de
acuerdo al plan de estudios es
exponentes básicos
y ocurre lo mismo tenemos lecciones y
tareas durante unas semanas y al final
de ese periodo tenemos un examen y
supongamos que en ese examen nuestro
estudiante obtiene un 70% sabe mucho del
tema pero todavía hay algunas lagunas
bastante importantes
voy a colorear estas lagunas lo que tuvo
bien en este examen está en color blanco
pero incluso estos exámenes son
imperfectos solo están mostrando el
conocimiento del estudiante y hay cosas
del tema que aparecen en el examen que
no sabe quizá algunos fueron errores por
descuido pero probablemente otros fueron
errores importantes por ejemplo esta
laguna puede que tenga que ver con no
saber qué sucede si se eleva algo a la
potencia cero o quizás se origina en una
laguna de los números negativos quizá
esta laguna surgió no porque los
exponentes básicos sean difíciles sino
porque hay una laguna en los números
negativos por lo que el estudiante no
sabe lo que va a suceder al elevar un
número negativo a una potencia positiva
entonces aquí hay una laguna pero aunque
nos hayamos ocupado de identificar estas
unas el grupo va a avanzar al siguiente
concepto la duración está establecida y
lo que es variable es que también
entienden los estudiantes a b c d
efe el siguiente concepto lo pondremos
en otro color este nuevo concepto se
presenta sobre todo lo que hemos
aprendido hasta ahora digamos que es
exponentes negativos ya puedes ver hacia
dónde vamos con esto ahora se está
volviendo un problema para el estudiante
hay lecciones y tareas el estudiante
está haciendo su mejor esfuerzo pero no
logra fijar el conocimiento entonces
cuando después de dos o tres semanas
presenta el examen el estudiante se topa
contra una pared y sólo consigue
contestar un 30% del material que
apareció en el examen el resto lo tuvo
mal en el sistema tradicional se diría
al estudiante le fue bastante mal en
este examen
quizá el estudiante debe trabajar más
duro quizás necesita tomar un camino
distinto quizás simplemente la materia
es muy complicada para el estudiante
pero cuando se observa lo que está
sucediendo resulta bastante claro que no
tiene nada que ver
el nivel de habilidades del estudiante
ni tiene que ver necesariamente con la
dificultad del tema sino que ha estado
acumulando lagunas durante todo el
aprendizaje y en algún punto esas
lagunas se tornan tan debilitantes que
el estudiante se topa contra una pared y
comienza a reprobar y si no logra
regresar a superar esas lagunas nunca va
a poder comprender realmente los
exponentes negativos ni podrá comprender
correctamente logaritmos ni álgebra más
avanzada y así sucesivamente hemos visto
esto ya sea en nosotros mismos o en
algunos de nuestros amigos o familiares
se topan contra muros el argumento en el
que creemos en khan academy no es que no
sea brillante no es que el tema sea
difícil sino que se le está forzando a
ir a un ritmo establecido y para
comprender lo absurdo que puede ser esto
imaginemos qué pasaría si hiciéramos
otras cosas de nuestra vida de esa forma
por decir algo construir una casa le
decimos al contratista tenemos dos
semanas para construir los cimientos haz
lo que puedas y él pone los cimientos
dos semanas después llega el inspector y
dice veamos el concreto aún está húmedo
aquí esta parte no cumple la
reglamentación le voy a dar un 80% y
nosotros decimos muy bien aprobamos
construyamos el primer piso y de nuevo
empezamos a construir el primer piso
tal vez llueve algunos materiales nos
llegan y cuando vuelve el inspector
después de un par de semanas dice muy
bien le voy a dar un 70%
y decimos genial es aceptable ahora
construyamos el segundo piso pero
entonces cuando estamos construyendo el
segundo piso toda la estructura comienza
a colapsar y si nuestra reacción fuera
la reacción típica que tenemos en torno
a la educación diríamos no necesitamos
más inspecciones o necesitamos mejores
contratistas pero el problema fue el
proceso estamos restringiendo de manera
artificial el tiempo que necesitamos
para hacer algo lo que garantiza un
resultado variable nos damos a la tarea
de identificar las lagunas pero
construimos encima de ellas esto es el
aprendizaje
adicional y hay quienes argumentan que
si se presiona a la gente para avanzar a
un ritmo como éste todos van a acumular
lagunas y se toparán contra una pared en
algún momento todos lo hemos sentido
entonces el aprendizaje para el dominio
dice en lugar de hacer que todos vayan
al mismo ritmo personalizamos y la
personalización en este contexto
significa dejar que la gente vaya a su
propio ritmo el aprendizaje tradicional
tiene un ritmo establecido y una
comprensión variable mientras que el
aprendizaje para el dominio se basa en
la personalización el ritmo es variable
y suponemos que los estudiantes
alcanzarán un mayor nivel de dominio o
competencia entonces expectativas altas
sobre dominio o competencia y estas dos
palabras pueden significar cosas
distintas en diferentes contextos en un
sistema de aprendizaje para el dominio
quizá el estudiante esté listo para los
números negativos y tal vez después de
unas semanas tome algún tipo de
evaluación para obtener tanta práctica y
retroalimentación como sea posible y su
resultado sea similar al del estudiante
del primer ejemplo
quizá obtenga un 80 por ciento en un
sistema de aprendizaje para el dominio
no le vamos a decir al estudiante muy
bien vamos a avanzar a exponentes
básicos lo que hacemos es decirle porque
nos sigues trabajando en los números
negativos para superar esas lagunas
quizá esto le tome al estudiante un poco
más de tiempo pero al final va a poder
llenar esas lagunas quizá aún queden
unas cuantas pero el punto es que pueda
volver y revisar y asegurarse de
eliminarlas para que no se vuelvan
debilitantes lo ideal es que supere
todas las lagunas y ahora ya estará
listo para exponentes básicos
aquí sostengo que ahora que va a
enfrentarse a los exponentes básicos
el estudiante realmente podrá ser capaz
de comprender los más rápidamente porque
ya no lo confundirán tanto los
exponentes negativos pero si después de
tomar alguna evaluación o al hacer una
práctica aún resulta que tiene lagunas
tiene todo el tiempo necesario para
regresar y superarlas el principio en el
aprendizaje para el dominio es que el
estudiante construirá unos cimientos
sólidos de manera que nunca se tope
contra una pared cuando llegue a
exponentes negativos
entiende bien los números negativos
entiende bien los exponentes así que
podrás seguir y seguir y seguir y en can
academic creemos que si aprendes de este
modo en efecto algunos temas te tomarán
un poco más pero si inviertes tiempo ahí
los siguientes temas te tomarán menos
tiempo y entenderás más y sobre todo y
hemos visto estudios de eficacia sobre
esto aprenderás mejor y más rápido y al
final no te enfrentarás contra ningún
tipo de barrera
a diferencia del primer estudiante con
los exponentes negativos